Let us talk about what is design. Design in journal takes us input some sort
of needs, so goals or functions. It gives us output that's specification of
this structure of some artifact that satisfies those needs and goals and
functions. Note that the artifact need not be a physical product.
It can be a process. A program, a policy. Some example for
design, design a robot that can walk on water.
Design a search engine that can return the most relevant answer to a query.
The Federal Reserve Bank designs and monitor the policy to optimize the economy.
Note the design is very wide ranging, open ended and
ill-defined. In problem solving, typically the problem remains fixed, even
as the solution evolves. In design, both the problem and the solution co-evolve.
The problem evolves as the solution evolves. We are studying design and
AI because we are working with AI agents that can do design.
At least potentially, we want AI agents that can design other AI agents.